all right Aaron hi Erin uh were you from
originally where'd you grow up um South
Central
what part
um like off of Florence and Broadway's
Lawson Vernon
of money I always lived on Broadway
tell me about your family growing up um
well I lived with my parents tell us
about 11 uh when my mom my dad it was a
lot of abuse and so like just it was
rough you know growing up with them and
we gotta we ended up leaving with our
grandma and grandpa
when we were at it when I was 11 I was
there for about two years with my
grandma grandpa but you know I didn't
really take losing my parents too well
and I didn't really understand so I
started like like being bad and I'm
getting kicked out of school fighting
just being real rebellious and um I hit
the system when I was 13 because I
started getting arrested stood in a
stealing cars you know just um
just doing whatever in the streets and
um I started going to jail and after I
went to jail when I was 13 my grandma
they dropped I became awarded the state
and um after that it was a wrap I just
spent I went to a mental hospital right
before that because I didn't take it too
well and I I tried overdose on pills and
um so I was in the middle Institution
for like maybe like three weeks I think
it was got out and then um went back to
jail my grandma dropped custody um came
over to the state basically from 13 18 I
spent
enjoyed our Hall Camp back in and out
foster homes um placements you know
um I was a adopted like adopted or not
adopted but I got a caregiver when I was
about 16 and a half almost 17
um from a a woman that used to be from
the same game you know gang was meeting
but she was older you know and uh she
used to do that like three ways and
stuff for all the homies when they were
busted so she you know when you do three
ways you hear the conversation so she
basically
we hear about conversations all the time
so I did eight months flat and then I
got out for a week and went back for 11
months and so she would like she was you
know she heard all the conversations
three way is what three ways like um
you're in jail and you call somebody and
then they they they are you give them
the number that you want to call and if
they don't take their calls or something
like you know it's like basically
someone who accepts clear calls and then
they do a three-way meeting they'll call
somebody else for you so they're on the
line but they can hear your conversation
to whatever else you're talking to
what's what's the reason for doing it um
it's just it's just for homies or like
it's just like a lot of people that get
busted like they have when how many
people you know the phone calls are the
most important thing because that's all
from jail yeah yeah and people pay for
three ways you know because um you know
you just gotta you have to you they
still clear calls and they could call
other people on the same line oh I see
so um so yeah she uh basically um I
needed somewhere I was about to get out
I didn't have nowhere to go and no
places or if they want to take me no
more because I've been there to eight
different ones so she ended up long
story short she wanted to go find my mom
it didn't work out well and she said you
know I'll take you in you want and I
just thought it was going to be like oh
she'll take me in I'm gonna just run the
muck afterwards like you know just the
favor but I should end up taking cushion
to me and she'd been you know she's
she's been a part of my life like since
then you know she still is and um she's
been nothing but like good to me you
know and um
hello so I got out but I just went right
back to jail so I continuing the game my
life was just appeared just gang banging
in the streets I didn't give I wasn't
really too much into drugs because weed
and stuff but I was just just trying to
like get my title in the streets and
went back to jail for another year
caught a murder case in and out and and
um beat it got out
and um you know I was just you know I
was just in the street I I was doing
kind of good you know like I thought I
was a 27 and then I got married
I was 30.
um guy now I'm just a separated and so
is it where I married for six years
mostly didn't work out and um now I'm
just stuck in my addiction in the street
you know like uh I never used to be like
this before like you know like
dirty clothes not showering for two
three days not eating like wearing
orange hat with Red Socks like I just
lost myself one day became a year
already you know and it's like I I just
stuck in my addiction I'm just straight
you adapt to the environment and I'm
just you know what is your drug
Christmas yeah I just can't seem to
shake it or Let It Go and it's like it
just it truly does take over you in a
sense because everybody says it's all in
your mind no the [__] some people it is
you know everybody's different but the
other's just like damn you know like
they can't a guy can't stop it you know
you know
but um your childhood was there any
abuse in it no it was a lot of like uh
like it was never sexual inside like
when the recently like this being in the
street like uh you know stuff happens
but uh when I was growing up it was more
physical like uh my dad would be like
here my mom maybe my mom and and I was
here so I'll like try to help and then
he was just like like hit me or he'll
make us watch her and beat her
for like hours like
I was a lot of like physical abuse you
know from my my sister was a lot of
mentor on her like you know like she
ain't [__] like you're a horse like your
mom's type of stuff with her so she she
grew up thinking like if you don't hear
me you don't love me but she likes she
likes that type of stuff I I I was the
same too hitting my girlfriends and
stuff but I know you don't hit the
people you love you know not supposed to
and like the sexual stuff they didn't
never last I never had any problems with
that until like this this last year I
you know like um
I didn't get raped or Nothing But like I
I but you know when you do drugs
sometimes you go into like we call it a
Como status because you've been up for
so many days when you fall asleep you
actually you're like you can't wake up
for [__] you know and
and I guess you mean I I was coma status
trying to watch other people asleep
because I don't like I have a thing
where people when you're asleep you
don't know you might touch yourself you
might get a boner you don't know and
like people are all right there just
looking at you I don't like that so I'll
be I was trying to watch them and and I
was tired I just I ended up passing out
in one of my brother's friends and stuff
um I just came in
he's like just like you know like you
know I guess grope me or whatever but I
didn't remember nothing until somebody
told me like hey you didn't you know
this happened to you and I was like what
the [__] and since then it it hit a
total on me because it's different you
know it's like it's this purse it's
private you know
this is it affects everybody differently
I guess so so you were born
uh female yeah female I'm a female
you're female yeah but you you're I'm a
lesbian I like girls um but uh I like I
don't want to be a guy like you know but
I just I always go pee on that but uh I
um I'm okay what do I like being a girl
you know I like being a woman you're
just a little more masculine yeah I
think just always been a tomboy like
just like a boy I don't like I like dogs
they always get dirty you know I mean
but
but yeah
yeah I think the world is much more
accepting of that now yeah it is
everybody everybody's pretty much gained
nowadays yeah I mean crystal meth they
all seem to be my myth man that [__] no
job I never thought I would have been
like so like
it makes me feel like I know that I
would be like stuck on it like this like
you know I mean I never thought I'd be
hitting the Pookie you know like or I
never thought I'd be
kicking it with people like God damn I'm
here just I don't like no y'all
[__] are here but I'm just here
because I'm trying to hit a boy you know
where are you living now uh actually ran
the true like um
I'm even actually like in a tent right
now you know uh but you're not a skid
row you're in South Central no I'm off
of over there on Broadway and Rosecrans
where all the Traders are and stuff
right I know I I I actually I live in a
tent and um you know I had opportunity I
had an apartment and I still do have an
apartment but I gave it to my little
sister and the lady who took her in
because they got they were in the street
and like you know I could handle being
in the street I'm grown you know and she
got kids and [__] so I'm like [__] it
just take it you know the wrench cheaps
like 700 for a studio and that's never
found really
yeah but I didn't think it was gonna be
this hard for me in the street you know
like [__] in buckets I mean using a
fire hydrant to wash my hands like it's
like
one day becomes two days without
showering like three days four days you
know like I don't want like five days
without showering you know and it's like
I'm a female I mean females you know we
got it's open wound you know you guys
you got to stay clean where it's like
you get you're so used to it it's like
but the [__] is unhumanitary like you
know in bags using socks to wipe your
ass like
is
it's kind of like sad but you know I
mean that's where I'm at right now like
just like you know I'm gonna say kind of
like [__] it you know in a way like but
I I know like I gotta like snap out of
it somehow you know what emotions do you
go through most
[Music]
um mostly like I feel ashamed you know
like depression a little bit
yeah I feel like because this is like um
you know the dope I guess brings out the
worst in people sometimes you know and
and I lost a lot of my Integrity you
know my self-respect I have I don't
really have self-control whatsoever you
know so it makes me sad you know it
makes me feel ashamed of myself you know
depressed but
you know I
suicide thing in my head for a long time
you know but I try to push that out
because you know like I I had to try to
hate myself you know in January you know
you tried to hang yourself yeah you know
and uh
somebody had came you know and I like
trying to help help what did help you
know and um like about two weeks later I
found out that my uh my ex-girlfriend's
brother but we were like long-term
long-time friends he actually hung
himself six months prior and yeah he did
die you know and um so angry like you
know like I'm never gonna see him again
like not even in heaven or wherever we
go because you know that's a forbid you
know that's like one of the worst ones
the worst ones suicide and we'll never
meet again and it just affected all in
his family like I know there's people
out there that love me I know like if I
were to go it's like I'm free of my
everything I'm free of my my like free
of myself I feel like rest or like take
these God take my misery type of [__]
but what about all the people you do
behind that do live you love me you know
like I'm [__] up how many more lives you
know just because my life's [__] up
because I can't handle I can't handle it
or I can't get out of the hole that I
got stuck in you know there's plenty of
ropes but I'm just like
just don't I mean I'm just I guess I
don't want to try hard enough I guess or
what do you do for money now
man for money for still
I don't like stuff for people I know I
don't I really don't I don't like that
but I have
um still coming up usually I like
Grocery Stores
um
anything flipping things selling drugs
yeah I mean if I can selling girls if I
could you know I mean other people's
[__] like
come UPS
credit cards type of [__] your friends
I have friends but I don't really talk
much about many I don't talk to a lot of
my friends like you know more because uh
I distance myself so much because I
didn't want my people to see me like
this because I I always when I was
married or you know something happened
with one of the kids you know and that
destroyed me of my wife
so then my wife we were happy together
we had a happy family that it was it was
great you know we had our own place I
was doing Roofing I used to be a roofer
for local 36 yeah I mean and and um we
just fell apart you know we couldn't
handle what happened happened and um
they just
it just [__] me up so bad that I I
just I just started using as much as I
could trying to like overdose I couldn't
deal with the pain but she's been almost
a year or two years and the Pain's still
there so sad I just wasted all that time
and got more just dug a ditch for myself
you know how old do you know I'm I'm 37.
37.
you had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
who has done differently
[Music]
I would have uh
I wouldn't start using drugs I would not
have gotten though because I was like
man when we when I turned I'ma stop at
this age [__] no man that she gotta hold
it hold me so that quick it's like I
can't let it go for [__] you know I mean
like like at all you know I mean it
would I would definitely
have be think twice before I make
decision decisions I've made you know
and living on the streets makes
everything tougher man living on the
street the streets is cold now before
the streets was it was I could have like
it's all day you know it ain't nothing
but this is a different bargaining
issues now you can't trust nobody you
gotta like if you can't leave you can't
leave your phone you can't leave nothing
I see somebody get jacked in 15 seconds
for a hundred dollars like what the [__]
because you fell asleep you know like
dozed off because it's high you know is
the dope is heavy you know like like the
ferry nowadays you know what's after
that death you know I mean that's just
so strong it kills you yeah and and [__]
man like it's
the streets is cold it's cold outside
what's your biggest fear
never getting back on my feet never
never becoming the person that I I don't
want to become the person that I was I
want to be better you know but I wanna I
wanna I'm a person that grew up like
respects self-respect Integrity is very
important to me and like I lost it you
know and so I I need that back I need to
find
find myself again and just get back on
my feet because I know I could be better
you think the childhood you had kind of
set you up for oh yeah yeah
I I don't blame my mother father you
know I really don't but I do hold them
accountable because they I'm abusive
because I hit every girl I've been with
because of my father I believe it
because seeing him and I hate that but I
am abusive I mean it's bad like word and
in the drugs they didn't help at all
like my childhood
formed me into who I became and it's my
it's on me because I chose it but damn
maybe if my parents would just
baby did a little better or just not
giving up on me or giving up on
themselves
everybody says it's always because your
kids will do better without you nah man
a kid unless you're like shouting your
kids and being like that's it then yeah
yeah but every kid every kid needs their
parents you know their love is what's
most important that helps you grow you
know and like [__] somebody's not even
my mother her she her love is so strong
as a mother that it it it filled all the
it filled everything in me that I needed
to be to become to get through that
stage when I was young you know because
I went through that stage of just like
gangbang and not giving a [__] like hey
man I'm gonna drop me off on the corner
pick me on the next on the next corner I
walk down this [__] because I
like I wasn't tripping you know what I
mean I just like wanted just to hurt
people on my enemies you know but
if my child maybe you know if it was a
little bit maybe if they just tried a
little harder you know then I would have
been a better person you know or I could
have became I wouldn't be where I'm at
today
but but I'm here and the only thing I
could do is like take responsibility for
my actions and try to get get on my feet
before it's too late because
it's either death
or I get it right because I don't want
to be 40 and be in the same place I was
when I was 17. [__] no
okay
all right man thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
thank you for letting me share it all
right thank you very much